Well, good morning again, church.
What a morning. It has been already in 15 minutes.
I mean, we just get such a, a joy to see what God is doing.
It's an honor to be a part of, just to kind of sit back
and watch and see, uh, what God is doing among us.
It's awesome. And
so if you are new to our church, my name's John.
I'm one of the pastors here.
If I have not had the privilege of meeting you yet,
I would love to, uh, after the service,
before the service sometime
during the week, we'd love to do that.
Uh, please come say hello.
As we get into God's word today though,
I wanna ask a question.
Uh, start with this.
Have you ever been tempted to take revenge on someone?
Uh, if you have raise your hand, like, uh,
I might see my hands up, right?
So, uh, if you are not raising your hand,
I'm probably gonna ask you if you're lying about that, okay?
Uh, so it's okay to be honest here, right? We can do that.
All of us, all of us have been tempted
to take revenge.
It's almost innate to us.
Like even from a very young age,
when you think about like the playground picture, right?
One kid throws a punch. What's gonna happen next?
That kid's throwing a punch back, right?
It's just gonna happen. That's how it works.
And in, in, in many ways, we have to learn as we get older
how to control those reactions.
So we don't just throw hands on the playground all the time.
We've gotta figure out how to control that action.
But here's the thing about that.
Sometimes it's not just about the action, right?
It takes something supernatural to get that desire,
not merely out of our actions,
but to get that desire out of our hearts, to get that desire
for revenge out of the deepest part of us.
Because it still shows up, doesn't it?
Even if we don't throw hands on the playground,
we still see it in here.
You get that less than stellar job performance review
and you, you're tempted to slander or gossip about your boss
or someone badmouth you on social media.
And so you're tempted at school
to trip 'em in the hallway just to make him laugh
and make people laugh at him, right?
Or that person steals money from you
and you're tempted to just drop the hammer legally.
Or even your spouse annoys you in some way.
And so you feel like this, I'm gonna silent
treatment, that kind of thing.
And this vengeful right? And on and on we could go.
It's not just about those things, it's about
so many other things because of our sinful flesh.
That desire for vengeance is deep in our hearts, all of us.
So what's the answer? What do we do with that?
Well, let's see what God's word says
starting in one Samuel Chapter
24, 1 Samuel 24.
As we continue the series through this book,
nearing the end, we'll come into a couple weeks from now.
We'll hit the end of it. But I just wanna read the first
seven verses of one Samuel 24 to start.
It's gonna set the context.
It's very quick moving pace of this start.
It's gonna set the context for everything else though
as you'll see the rest of today.
So first Samuel of 24, just the first seven verses,
When Saul returned from following the Philistines,
remember he had been distracted from chasing David by going
to have to fight the Philistines.
He returned, meaning he came back to the fight he was told,
behold David's in the wilderness of in Getti.
Then Saul took 3000 chosen men out of all of Israel
and went to seek David
and his men in front of the wild goats rocks.
And he came to the sheep folds, by the way,
where there was a cave and Saul went into relieve himself.
That means what you think it does.
So just we're not gonna talk about that again. Okay?
Now, David
and his men were sitting in the innermost parts of the cave
and the men of David said to him, here's the day
of which the Lord said to you.
Behold, I'll give your enemy into your hand.
You shall do to him as it shall seem good to you.
So David arose and stealthily cut off a
corner of Saul's robe.
And afterward David's heart struck him
because he had cut off a corner of Saul's robe.
He said to his men, the Lord forbid
that I should do this thing to my Lord.
The Lord's anointed to put out my hand against him,
seeing he is the Lord's anointed.
And so David persuaded strongly, his men with these words
and did not permit them to attack Saul and Saul rose up
and left the cave and went on his way.
Now God, we know this is not the end of the chapter
and there's a lot more left.
But we pray this. We just get this picture, this framing
of the scene that you have shown us
so much already in these few verses.
Teach us more, change our hearts more by virtue of
what you've shown here and what you will teach us.
Holy Spirit, this is your job to do that.
Speak through your word
into our hearts and give us eyes to see it.
In Jesus' name, amen.
Now the rest of the chapter, we'll get
to a little bit later, it's full
of really important dialogue between Saul and David.
We'll get to that. But these first seven verses pretty much
contained the whole of the story of this chapter.
Saul was anointed by God as Israel's first king.
He had lost that kingship effectively
by denying God as his king.
And so God anointed David as the replacement king.
And so the tension is
that they're both anointed at this point.
But we see how God is, is shifting the leadership
of the nation to David over time.
But Saul is still effectively in that position
and in his jealousy over losing it to David,
he was seeking David's life, trying
to eliminate David from the equation over and over and over.
Yet we have seen God protected David from
Saul repeatedly.
But here's the question we haven't asked yet.
Was Saul safe from David?
David was safe from Saul. Saul couldn't even find him.
But was Saul safe from David? That's the question.
Chapter 24 begins to answer.
David comes into prominence.
How would he respond to the fact
that Saul is now less prominent
and David has opportunities like Saul has had opportunities?
Well, here's what we learned right away is that David's men
wanted power by force, right?
We saw that David's men for sure at least,
they wanted power by force.
See, Saul is on the hunt for David
and this is just west of the dead Sea.
Uh, it's in the middle of nowhere. It's a wilderness.
It's really harsh conditions.
And so Saul ended up in one of these caves in the area
that dot that whole area.
If you've ever been able to be over there,
it's incredible to see it.
And it just happened to be the cave that David
and his men were hiding in.
Now, David's men read the situation
and they saw this as God's providence,
that God would deliver Saul into David's hand
to finally rid himself of this
constant death threat against David's life.
He's got an opportunity. That's why they said
what they said in verse four.
Look again. Here is the day of which the Lord said to you.
Behold, I'll give your enemy into your hand.
You shall do to him as it shall seem good to you.
Like they, they looked at the situation.
That's the way they were certain
that they read the situation correctly.
This was God's will to free them from this threat.
Was it though, because David had a
different interpretation, right?
Even though he had every clear opportunity
to take Saul's life in that cave, he merely cut off a part
of Saul's robe.
Now, to us, that's not that big a deal,
like just a little piece of fabric.
But, but many believe that it more
than just David showing Saul
that I could have killed you and I didn't.
That it meant more that it actually alludes back
to chapter 15 when Saul and was with Samuel and,
and Samuel told Saul that God was taking the kingdom away.
And Saul grabbed his robe and it tore
and Samuel said, Hey, that's
what God's doing with the kingdom.
He's tearing it away from you that this in some way
alludes back to that moment.
'cause that robe that Saul was wearing,
it was a symbol of the kingship.
It it was something that showed
that he was the only one who could wear it.
It was probably had some nice fringes on the edge of it.
That was the way often those kings looked at the time.
And that's why I think David was so convicted
by this act that he did.
Verse five, it says David's heart struck him
because of what he had done.
Why? Because David cutting off the corner
of the robe could have been construed
that it was a symbolic effort to take the kingship by force.
That he says the robe is mine in a sense
that he was pushing Saul off the throne
and taking this position himself.
That's the way it could have.
And I think that's why David was really like, oh,
I shouldn't have done that because that's
what people would've read into it.
And so what we learn again is David was sensitive
to God's work in his heart.
He's continuing to prove himself more and more worthy.
He's growing in his trust
that the Lord's gonna work all this out.
And so he's settling into that reality.
That's why we see verse six as an example.
Look at what David said in verse six.
He said, the Lord, Yahweh forbid that I should do this thing
to my Lord little L.
He's talking about his Lord the king Saul.
He's still respectful of the position
he calls Saul the Lord.
Yahweh's anointed.
Lord forbid that I should do this
to put out my hand against him,
seeing he is the Lord's anointed.
Again, David respected, understood.
His fear of the Lord was bigger than his fear of Saul.
We'll see even more later as we get
to the dialogue later in the chapter.
But David knew again, Saul had been anointed by God as well.
Even though Saul was shown his true colors,
he was trying to kill David.
He was showing he wasn't truly following the Lord.
But David feared God enough not to take Saul's life.
'cause the command was don't touch the Lord's anointed.
And so David respected that, knew that feared God enough
that even though it might have seemed providential,
That God had provided Saul right in front of him
to kill him, to take Saul out.
David did not want to take revenge.
So watch what happened next. Saul left the cave.
Saul knew none of this had happened, right?
He's le he he left.
He doesn't even notice his robe is a little shorter.
He doesn't know any of that. Watch now verses eight
through 22, and again this is just dialogue
between Saul and David.
Everything's happened already,
but now we see how it plays out.
Verse eight afterward, David also arose
and went outta the cave and he called after Saul.
Now let's just stop for a second.
Remember, David knew Saul was hunting him.
David knew Saul could never find him.
And now he's coming outta the cave
and saying, Hey Saul, I'm here.
Right? Like that's a bit of a risk, but you see his heart.
So he went outta the cave. He called
after Saul, my Lord the king.
When Saul looked behind him, David bowed with his face
to the earth and pay Domage.
And David said to Saul, why do you listen to the words
of men who say, behold, David seeks your harm.
Behold, this day, your eyes have seen
how the Lord gave you today into my hand in the cave.
Some told me to kill you, but I spared you.
I said, I will not put out my hand against my Lord
for he is the Lord's anointed.
See my Father, see the corner of your robe in my hand for
by the fact that I cut off the corner
of your robe and did not kill you.
You may know and see that there's no wrong
or treason in my hands.
I have not sinned against you,
though you hunt my life to take it.
May the Lord judge between me and you.
May the Lord avenge me against you,
but my hand shall not be against you.
As the proverb of the ancients says,
outta the wicked comes wickedness.
But my hand shall not be against you.
After whom has the King
of Israel come out After whom do you pursue
after a dead dog, after a flea, may the Lord
therefore be judged and give sentence between me and you
and see to it and plead my cause
and deliver me from your hand.
As soon as David is finished speaking these words to Saul,
Saul said, is this your voice?
My son David Saul lifted up his voice and wept
and said to David, you are more righteous than I
for you have repaid me good.
Whereas I have repaid you evil
and you've declared this day how you have dealt well with me
and that you did not kill me.
When the Lord put me into your hands
for if a man finds his enemy, will he let him go away safe?
So may the Lord reward you with good for
what you've done to me this day.
Now behold, I know that you shall surely be king.
The kingdom of Israel shall be established in your hand.
Swear to me, therefore, by the Lord
that you will not cut off my offspring
after me, that you will not destroy my name
outta my father's house.
David swore this to Saul.
And Saul went home, but David
and his men went up to the stronghold.
Now, if you remember from previous chapters,
you remember there were be there.
There were bunches of people who were feeding Saul the lie
that David was
after him too, that he better take out David
first or David's gonna kill him,
which was partly the reason David did this here.
He attempted peace by persuasion, by trying
to persuade Saul to change his mind.
He attempted peace by persuasion.
He knew people were feeding Saul the lie.
So he's like, Hey Saul, let me show you.
Lemme try to persuade you. That's not true.
And there was a masterclass given by David right here.
How he goes about this is just phenomenal.
He's proving to to Saul
that there's no a vengeance in David's heart
or else Saul would've been dead by now
and watch how he did this.
Watch how David handled this situation in in verse eight.
It shows his posture even was a humble posture, bowing low
before Saul.
He was not coming in arrogance.
He asked Saul to consider the facts of the situation
compared to what Saul had heard.
Here's what actually happened today, Saul.
It doesn't match, right? David even appealed to scripture
as part of his defense saying that,
Hey Saul, you believe this too?
Like don't you see this is
what I would've done if I was wicked.
And David ultimately entrusted the whole situation
to the Lord as the judge between them.
Now here's what's interesting about this.
The way Saul responded to David.
It seemed to work like what David tried to do here.
Saul was almost seeming to agree. Look at verse 17 again.
He said to David, you're more righteous than I.
You've repaid me good. I've repaid you evil.
You've declared how you've dealt well with me.
You didn't kill me Like verse 20.
He even agrees, I know you shall be surely king.
The kingdom of Israel shall be established.
Swear that you won't cut me off.
Like that sounds like a defeated man.
Sounds like a repentant heart, doesn't it?
And again, if we only take this chapter that might be true,
we might see, oh yeah, Saul leaves lets him go
and David leaves and everything is good again.
But we can't take just this chapter
like we can't take just this chapter.
We don't read in isolation.
See, Saul actually continued to seek David's life
throughout the rest of the book.
Saul knew what he said to David was true.
And look how far he had fallen. He knew this was wrong.
He knew David was to be the king and Saul kept after him.
Now, as we consider the chapter
as a whole, the facts
of the situation are pretty straightforward,
pretty simple to understand, right?
We, we've heard this story probably before.
We can clearly grasp what David did here.
He did the right thing, he didn't,
you can see it pretty clearly.
But we need to ask a couple questions of it
and really ask a couple questions of ourselves
in light of it.
So I just want you to, I started with this a little bit.
I want you to play this out in your head.
I, I think put yourself in this situation.
So there's a man who is committing all
of his resources toward taking your life.
It puts you on the run. It upends everything in your life.
You can't live in any normalcy. He's after you.
But then all of a sudden, that man ends
up right in front of you.
He doesn't know you're there. He's right in front of you.
And everyone around you is telling you
that God put him there so
that you can end this battle once and for all.
What would you do? You ever seen that TV show
that talks about this, puts you in a situation like
what would you do in this situa?
What would you do here? Would you
take vengeance on Saul?
Would you take Saul's life?
He's been throwing spears at you, sending troops at you,
trying to kill you over and over and over.
He's right there in front of you.
You have the opportunity to kill him. Would you?
Now, I'm fully aware this is an extreme case.
It's really hard to put ourselves in a situation like that.
I hope none of us are ever in a situation like that before.
But the reality is, every day you
and I face similar temptations
to take vengeance
in a million other ways.
We are tempted similarly, that's where this gets
to the heart for us.
See, here's the fundamental question.
The fundamental question of all this.
Will I trust God to fight my battles
or will I try to take matters into my own hands?
Will I trust God to fight the battle
or will I take matters in my own hands?
Do I think I have a right to revenge?
Now next week, we'll see, David had some room
to grow in this, but he passed the test here, didn't he?
He, he's presented with an unexpected opportunity in the
cave and it reveals that his heart was right.
He really was a man after God's own heart.
He didn't want to do anything that would hinder
God's work through him.
And we've said it the entire series, we've said it today.
It all comes back to a person's trust in the Lord.
Do we trust God in this or not?
This is how David said it to Saul in verse 12.
Remember this, May the Lord judge
between me and you.
May the Lord avenge me against you,
but my hand shall not be against you.
And then in verse 15, may the Lord be judged
and give sentence between me and you and see to it
and plead my cause and deliver me from your hand.
You see that right? David trusted the Lord
to resolve the situation.
He could have taken matters into his own hands.
He could have done it right there.
But think about the potential consequences.
If he would've done that, there probably would've been
some who would've aligned around Jonathan as the next king.
Jonathan was Saul's son. Next in line.
Many people would've said, well, David did that.
No, we're gonna, we're Jonathan's the one.
People would not have trusted David as much
because of what he did to Saul.
Like if you're gonna take his life, we sure might.
Well, you might take my life too. I don't know.
He would've been disobeying the Lord's command
and that would have led to God's discipline in his life,
which would've been painful.
So you can see all of these in, in spite
of this apparent victory, he would have won oversaw.
There would've been great deal of pain.
Maybe some of you have been there, right?
I've been there. Have you ever taken vengeance
on someone who hurt you?
And in the moment it felt really good.
Like man, I got 'em.
But then the pain came, the consequences came.
It didn't really turn out the way you thought it would.
Consequences came in your life.
You never could have predicted all
because of vengeance.
Listen, that's why Romans 12 is so instructive for us today.
Because if we are Christians, if you are a Christian,
we ought to be different in this
not only for other people's sake,
that we don't hurt other people, but also for our own souls.
We've got to be different in this.
Now here's a little preview.
After Easter, late April,
we're gonna take a deep dive into Romans 12.
The whole chapter, just spend weeks in that chapter
because it shows us what it looks like
to truly follow Jesus, to love him with all that we are
and to live a life that looks like his.
I'm really excited about that.
But, but I wanna just show you a little glimpse
with this topic today, what Romans 12 says
about this issue.
Listen,
bless those who persecute you.
Bless and do not curse them.
Repay no one evil for evil.
But give thought to do what is honorable in the sight
of all if possible.
So far as it depends on you live
peaceably with all.
Like is that not an incredible picture
of a transformed life, of a transformed heart,
of a different way of living?
That's radical, right? It's the same way.
Listen, this is not new.
It's the same way Jesus said it in the Sermon on
the Mount in Matthew five.
He's talking about the way
of the world versus the way of Christ.
Listen to what he says.
You've heard that it was said, an eye for an eye
and a tooth for a tooth.
Like that's the way of the world vengeance.
Pay it back equal.
But I say to you, do not resist the one who is evil.
But if anyone slaps you on the right
cheek, turn to him the other.
Also, if anyone would sue you
and take your tunic, let him have your cloak as well.
And if anyone forces you to go one mile, go
with him two miles, give to the one who begs from you.
Do not refuse the one who would borrow from you.
Does that not sound so radical to our modern ears
in a world dominated by vengeance,
by giving someone what they deserve?
This sounds crazy. They hurt me.
They should get it. This, this sounds crazy,
but it's the way of Christ, isn't it?
This is Jesus himself.
It's red letters in your Bible
if you want to take that right?
It's, it's Jesus saying this is the way it is.
Like Romans 12 said, instead of cursing someone,
you bless them
someone who hurts you.
You don't gossip about 'em,
you don't slander them, you bless them.
You never live the eye for an eye mantra of the world.
Instead, you look to honor people, you look
to build peace like David tried to do with Saul.
You try to be a peacemaker
and ultimately you leave your life.
You entrust your life to the sovereign God of the universe.
'cause Romans 12 continues with this.
Beloved never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God.
For it is written. Vengeance is mine.
I will repay, says the Lord.
To the contrary, if your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, give him something to drink for.
By so doing, you will heat burning coals on his head.
Do not be overcome by evil, but overcome evil with good.
Again, a life like that, a life lived like that, that
evidences a transformed heart, doesn't it?
'cause that's not natural to any of us.
That's not going to happen just because we're humans.
That's the opposite of what happens
because we're humans Where
you're not overcome by evil,
but instead you overcome evil with good
where you're not saturated
with the vengeance the world promotes.
Instead, you are so trusting in the Lord that you seek
to do good to those who hurt you.
You seek to forgive people when they hurt you.
You love your enemies as Jesus commanded us to do.
'cause David did that. And as he did that, Saul realized
that David had something that Saul didn't have.
He he saw something in in David that was different.
He was a better man than he, Saul said,
but we can't miss something else.
We have to assume that what David did, as Romans 12 said,
was just heaping burning coals on Saul's head
that Saul could not get away from it.
Which is maybe why Saul kept coming after him.
He felt so convicted by David's life.
He just felt so guilty over what he was doing to David.
He just couldn't stop. And it made him kind
of crazy either way.
Here's the point. As Christians,
instead of trying to gain power by force,
instead of trying to use vengeance
to solve our problems,
we are supposed to trust God.
We are supposed to trust God.
And that is what will brightly point
to our good God and savior.
In fact, we saw an example
of it this morning in the baptisms.
Maybe you missed it came in a little bit late.
But here, here's the testimony.
One of 'em how it went in this family,
the older brother came to Christ first,
but in their culture that caused pain
and shame to the family.
So much so that the younger brother tried to harm
and even kill the older brother.
Yet it was the older brother's constant faith
and transformed life of peace and love
and kindness that made the younger brother curious
about what he has, that he doesn't have.
Curious enough to read the Bible.
Eventually realizing that he was a sinner too
and that God loved him to send his son to be the sacrifice
to pay for our sins.
And this morning that older brother
baptized the younger brother, like,
do you understand what just happened?
Right? It would be like David baptizing Saul
and Saul saw it and came to faith
and he's like, oh, I guess I need what he has.
And David baptizes him.
Like, here's how the younger brother put it in his testimony
today, I know with all my heart
that Jesus Christ is the truth.
He is the way, the truth and the life. He saved me.
It changed my life forever.
I praise Jesus Christ for bringing me out
of darkness into his marvelous life.
Like that is only God.
Lemme give you a little glimpse. We did not plan all this
to happen today with this sermon like Monday.
I heard that story and I'm just like, okay,
this is the perfect illustration of exactly
what God has done through
a transformed life, through not taking vengeance
To Save a life.
That's what it does. That's what he can free you from.
That's what he can free us from the chains of that
enslavement to vengeance.
And then it frees other people as a result of that.
But here's the question though. Like that's incredible.
But here's the question. I was wrestling with this all week
and I hope you are as well.
How can we get there? How can we
ever get to that point?
'cause the world is only vengeance.
Give people what they deserve.
That's the river we're swimming in. How do we get to that?
I've been hinting at it the whole time,
but the answer is not getting up outta your chair later
and walking away, just trying harder not to be vengeful.
'cause you can't walk away from what's inside here.
And as much as David was a good example in this
moment, he is not perfect.
And there's nothing in him
that could actually transform the
deepest parts of who we are.
He can't do anything.
He can be an example for us, but he is limited.
That's why who this was really pointing us
to was the one called the Son of David,
The Christ, the Messiah, Jesus
who himself embodied power by humility.
Watch this. Jesus embodied power
by his humility.
We've said this before in the series, that David's life
was a type of Christ, meaning it pointed us forward.
David lived a thousand years before Jesus came, right?
David's life pointed us forward to something and and,
and give us images of something
that would be perfectly full.
He gives us hints
and through that lens, when we look through that lens,
the parallels start to jump off the page here.
Watch this. Just think of Jesus' life.
Jesus, when he first started,
after 30 years of obscurity, he lives in in Nazareth area
and at at the beginning of his public ministry,
he's baptized by John.
And as he comes up out of the water, it's in a sense
the public anointing of Jesus.
The Father speaks, it's my beloved
son, to whom I'm well pleased.
The dove of the Holy Spirit floats down.
It's, it's like this anointing has happened
and everybody notices this guy in a sense for the first time
yet three years go by before his cru.
So he spent three years with that anointing.
Yet he did not grasp for the fulfillment
of God's promises in that anointing prematurely
a lot like David, right?
David was anointed, had to wait through all kinds of things
to get to where he finally was given it by God instead
of taking it himself.
Watch this, Jesus in the wilderness in Matthew four,
he's tempted by the enemy.
Satan comes to him and says,
you can have all the kingdoms of the world
Right now.
And Jesus says, Nope, it's not time yet.
And he said, knowing I'll get those eventually
in God the father's time, but not yet.
And so he resisted. He did not take it by force.
Think of Jesus in the garden.
He's wrestling with this overwhelming nature
of carrying our sin to the cross.
Yet he said, he determined not as I will, but as you will.
My Father, full submission
to his father's will throughout his
Life Think of Jesus submitting
to the humiliation of the cross,
having every power at his disposal
to get down off the cross, to strike down those
who were captivating, who were who were killing him.
He had every opportunity to do that.
Yet here's what Philippians two
Says, Though he was in the form of God.
He did not count equality a thing to be grasped, held onto,
but he emptied himself by taking the form of a servant,
being born in likeness of men being found in human form.
He humbled himself by becoming obedient to the point
of death, even death on a cross.
That's humble submission, right?
Not grasping it himself, but humbly submitting.
Think about even now, Jesus.
Hebrews 10 teaches us when Christ offered
for all time a single sacrifice for sins,
he sat down at the right hand of God waiting from that time
until his enemies shall be made a footstool for his feet.
See, here's the point. We must have the same
mind in ourselves.
That humility of Christ
who had all the power, all the potential.
Yet he revealed it through his submission,
through his humble submission, trusting his father
to give him the authority he knew was his at right time.
In his father's time, his father's way, he said,
I'm not going to take it myself.
Even if it meant he had to suffer
For it, even die for it.
Yet, aren't you glad that because
He Did that
We have a hope in life and death
because Jesus waited, did not claim himself.
He submitted fully even to death.
We have a hope in life and death.
His perfect suffering serves us, saves us
such that we can then identify with him
as we suffer, as we wait.
But what that waiting does is it helps us grow,
helps us trust, helps us depend on him
to submit our lives to him, to work it all out for us.
Here's how I wanna close with this passage of scripture.
It perfectly encapsulates everything I've said today.
It points us to the hope of Christ forever. And Everett.
First Peter chapter two verses 19 through 24.
Go read it later as well.
But this is what we will lead into singing as a response
to this is what it says.
This is a gracious thing when mindful of God,
one endures sorrows while suffering.
Unjustly for what credit is it?
If you, when you suffer and are beaten
or when you sin are beaten for it, you endure.
But if when you do good and suffer for it, you endure.
This is a gracious thing in the sight of God.
For to this you have been called
because Christ also suffered for you,
leaving you an example.
So you might follow in his steps. He committed no sin.
Neither was deceit found in his mouth. When he was reviled.
He did not revile in return when he suffered,
he did not threaten,
but he continued entrusting himself to him
who judges justly.
He himself bore our sins in his body on the tree
that we might die to sin
and live to righteousness by his wounds.
You have been healed.
Let's stand together and let's respond to that Savior
for his goodness.